il y a deux jours cet habitant du
quartier du trait ses beats une nuit
mouvementée dans la nuit de vendredi à
samedi elle est réveillée vers 5 heures
du matin elle était moins en partie de
l' incendie le sinistre ravages des
garages et trois voitures au pied de son
immeuble
j'entendais des bruits en bas j'ai
regardé par ma fenêtre et avait les
banques est elle en train d'éteindre les
garages la du mont amba des jeunes j'ai
posté avait des pompiers pareil qui
s'était fait taper canarder que ça fait
peur quoi s'en prennent aux hlm neufs
sans toi
les faits se sont produits dans cette
impasse les pompiers de l'yonne sont
appelés pour éteindre ce feu de garage
mais à leur arrivée ils tombent dans un
piège alors qu'ils interviennent sur cet
incendie
une dizaine de jeunes les attaques avec
des pierres dont certaines grosses comme
le poing en atteste cette photo partager
sur les réseaux sociaux
bilan de cette agression deux
sapeurs-pompiers sont blessés il rêve
vraiment cette volonté délibérée de de
piéger de tendre une embuscade et de et
de les atteindre
physiquement personnellement et ça c'est
ça qui est un petit peu marquant parce
que bon on a eu souvent des véhicules
admis mais mais mais la has et les
personnes qui étaient qui était
directement visé par des projectiles qui
n'était pas petit donc voilà ça frappe
sa frappe les esprits
noura boujnane gère ce café situé en
face du quartier se florentine wahhabite
et pendant 25 ans ce quartier populaire
de la ville s'il ne cautionne pas les
actes perpétrés le week-end dernier
il tente d'expliquer les raisons qui ont
conduit à cette flambée soudaine de
violence ayad et l'aspect du quartier
mais de toute façon vous interrogerez
n'importe quelle personne ici au
quartier vous dira la même chose il ya
un délassement des quartiers de la part
des pouvoirs publics de l'avoir aimée je
pense que c'est dans tous les quartiers
sensibles qui sont comme ça est arrivé à
un moment tous les quartiers sont en
ébullition et arrive à un moment à la
moindre petite étincelle et va exploser
depuis le début de l'année c'est la
troisième agression subie par des
sapeurs pompiers dans le département de
l'yonne
une plainte a été déposée et une enquête
est ouverte elle a été confiée à la
brigade de gendarmerie de saint
florentin pour tenter de retrouver les
auteurs de cette agression